What is the strength of a human being
?
What is the strongest
? The
battle is about to
begin to get
the
answer.  The darkness increases to 2 times and the total is totaled. The
committee reef is performed by the 4 to 46 army.
Many equations are the way of the meeting.
Is it possible
to lead the team to victory by making full use of all of my own 10 body strategy ja?
I learned it as a team
Next, let's polish it
[Music
] And where the world is in the hidden village,
with the dream of being the strongest in the human world,
the writing will appear
[Applause]
[Music]
You yourself  Equipped with a
stealth avatar system To aim for the strongest new major day with your own hands,
learn the fruit of the sword.
It
's good to be the one who protects the whole car's recovery support.
The strongest liquor in the world
Even though the top of the battle has fallen, the main character
is 2 bolts and a reading striker